welcome to this video against Fritz Carl
see the room probably five t3ss the
difference between 5 and 63 but I never
really figured that one out this is a
different cell cable white obviously has
not cashed out so he can do those things
ok I'm just playing this super
conservative museum claiming that this
cannot be that dangerous for black
yeah going for the standard regrouping
yeah okay maybe I can get this Bishop
traded or not if not then I get the
night to g6 reroute in it okay so he
does not mind to trade okay
I'm a bit surprised that he just just
like that traded what is the idea
actually Bishop g5 on and maybe I'm
going to do something here ok he wants
to play this the standard the standard
queen Queen um into f3 knight f5 idea ok
Bishop to g5 is certainly possible it's
so very difficult I think for white you
get anything substantial in this very
solid position against this very solid
position
okay so question is do I play g6 or not
yeah I guess why not yeah both nights
are aiming aiming up towards f5 and with
g6 plate that's not going to happen any
time soon yeah he might prepare for
though Queenie two and then a form for
example
and that might be an idea okay not
happening trying to double their quickly
yeah this is also a little bit of an
issue here with the DFL but okay
honestly I can probably just do go here
and then go to Cannes covering that so
Luke the eighth and rope here just for
control of the d how and I just not
great on c6 but can we group that a very
equal ish position maybe I can play with
a five a forum still equal it's just a
good idea that I had or is it actually
better why not here actually knight on
c6 is not doing doing that much
chain that's an active square and before
as a move that you really have to I mean
this is how also weakening white quite
substantially yes so we're going to
trade this and now only Queen d6 yeah
it's not very exciting I know but um
yeah I really agree couldn't do much
about it maybe get them get the King to
the center
check okay so hmm I can't consider to
check with the pawn but it makes my
night look kind of silly so prolly not
see form I did not expect that one be
four is a weakness but maybe it's not
serious that's it's certainly possible
ok so here five preventing any before
move now yeah night c5 King III 96 and
it's not leading to too much oh now it
may be does lead to something now to a
form
hmm someone I deform it's not it's not
like fees or anything how do I get this
annoyed activated and maybe a 76 this
kind of way yeah okay
95mm
hmm that that I should have shrine
should have addressed somehow not sure
how exactly what I should have checked
should have looked at it
I came so king of two chicking lets you
one day for that's not so clear okay
check that was very badly played by me
getting into any kind of trouble yes
this is really not acceptable Gras our
third game drawn Jim I don't know is it
in equal why this what is pressing
somehow yeah I getting into trouble is
not acceptable here in this in this end
game black is a little bit better not
not not nothing substantial but I should
never be worse so okay I actually like
this idea but maybe I care i can improve
this somehow maybe this is what the comp
wants to do yeah okay you can't can do
that of course is sisters kind of way
and then kick him out with you six later
hey this is what i need to do check
checking a suddenly i am I was thinking
that I maybe have something here but it
didn't really didn't really materialize
but probably I should be more
conservative I still wanted to do
something and
not so clear that this is a great idea o
king d 6 is actually good marching up
hmm ok no I did not think about this
very much mm yeah there wasn't really
much going on yet I was I wasn't really
expect him expecting him on to to check
their thinking Bishop situ or Bishop b3
years or so not very ambitious but just
just very very very very equal ish
Bishop h6 was a mafia I should have
taken this chance I and that's that's
actually quite medium there's this move
what is this year no a nice tactic I
didn't think of Bishop h6 why Dwight has
to play something funky like this this
is actually not totally clear air comp
is just giving me a slider gem not like
a piece up so murky bishop age six is
however what I I should have considered
considered it at least this is ok no
problem whatsoever but it is also very
very boring yeah yeah do you know much
that you can do here c4 was kind of
surprising this is a move that can only
hurt wide let's say I mean it's giving
away squares those two and doesn't help
at all I mean I'm not overlooking c5
it's the only micro idea of the move The
Advocate was probably always kind of
draw very difficult to UM to make any
such
injured progress okay well thanks for
watching